Okay, in this section, we're going to do a quick review of calibration.
So, we've already covered what calibration is and why calibration is required.
But again, to reiterate, as we continue our calibration process,
calibration is required in order to create accurate compositions from CG renders and live video in Unreal Engine,
as a virtual camera needs to accurately simulate the physical camera used to capture the real-world video footage.
Now, the virtual camera position and orientation must closely match the position and orientation of the physical camera,
and the physical tracking information for that physical camera must match the exact timing of the video feed
to ensure that each video frame is accurately synced to the position and orientation of the camera at any given time.
When you complete this correctly, it is possible to evaluate your calibrated lens file for any focus and zoom position
by interpolating between the stored focus and zoom points.
And as we move through our tracking and calibration sections, we're going to be using this setup.
Each major component is required, but your solutions may differ than what we have on the Latte stage.
Now, one thing I want to note is that if you don't do lens distortion mapping before this,
you will run into the issue where the information you pass along for lens distortion and nodal point calibration
will not be accurate for your post team.
So, set extensions and anything that you need to add to your shots is going to be requiring you to do this calibration step.
Now, as you get started, there are some plugins that need to be enabled.
Again, camera calibration, lens distortion, which is depreciated, and then the OpenCV lens distortion.
Now, we move to OpenCV lens distortion instead of using our lens distortion plugin,
so that the OpenCV system is actually going to take on the bulk of that.
This was a change that was made in 5.0 as OpenCV takes over that function.
And again, as we move into more camera calibration, you'll see how that is important.
Now, there is one element that we built in our last class that you need to make sure is still active,
and that is our media profile.
If you have not already built your media profile, please refer to the other section.
The media profile is required as an asset that your lens file is going to utilize in order to locate your video source,
and that is used by Composer to overlay your CG elements in Unreal Engine inside the lens file asset editor for calibration.
Now, the media profile proxy configuration will automatically detect the number of sources available in your configuration,
but you may need to manually set that depending on what your setup is like.
Also, you are going to need additional lens files, as we've already built those,
if you have multiple cameras and lens configurations.
If you have a single camera body and multiple lenses, you will need a lens file for each.
Okay, so that finishes up this section.
And as we get ready, we're going to move on and talk about some other dependencies for calibration.